reason like Moses. Okay. So in this 1818
he said there will be a prophet like
Moses. Right. And at the end of
Deuteronomy he said there will be no
prophet like
Moses. So if there will be no prophet
like Moses but it says al be prophet
like Moses. How can you harmonize
between the two? How can you harmonize
between? There will be prophet like
Moses 188. So our prophet will be very
very similar to Moses. Yeah. Okay. But
if you read the end of the Deuteronomy
says since then there will be no prophet
like Moses who have no reason prophet
like Moses. Yes. Either you have to say
there's contradiction or the only way to
harmonize meaning there will be no
prophet like Moses from the Israelites
but there will be a prophet like Moses
from the non-Israelites. That's the only
way that you can help yourself to save
yourself from the contradiction of the
the the the trinity. I don't see the
contradiction. Okay. Is there is a
prophet
reading contract
step by step you read too fast with that
prophet is speaking to the other people.
So you may say to yourself how can we
know when a message has not been spoken
by the Lord. If what a prophet proclaims
in the name of the lord will come to
pass does not take place or come true
that is the message the law has must the
prophet has spoken I can't say this word
so do not be alarmed now immediately
this passage it gives you criteria how
to a true prophet and a false prophet if
a prophet speaks in the name of god and
the thing does not come to pass is a
false prophet and if he comes to pass is
what he's a true prophet I can show you
many prophecies that prophet Muhammad
said and he came to
Yeah, but I still like
So according to this you have to accept
it's a prophet. No really because
Muhammad was not the only prophet. Now
why I'm saying this criteria God said if
you say how do you know if you say in
your heart how do I know which the word
the lord has spoken? If a prophet speaks
in my name so how can I know it is the
word of god or not? So if prophet speaks
in the name of God and prophesy would
you say miracle is a good uh indicator
this man is sent by God with God. Yeah,
this what he says here. Did did
Muhammad make
Yeah. For example, Yeah. For example, he
would travel with his companions. There
were 300 300 of them and they had no
water to make and from his between his
fingers there was water coming out for
his companions. Likewise prophet
Muhammad when he's what do you call
it when he's
compat believers of of Quraysh ask him
for a miracle he divide the moose them
both there's many miracles the Quran
itself is a miracle you know
of these like you Moses yeah but before
going to that one I'm just showing him I
just like yeah but I I would say saying
oh I split the moon what for
That's not like going to someone and
healing them or resurrecting someone.
This is this is different level of Moses
gave miracle. What was the what was the
miracle of Moses?
The split in the city
bro 10 10 plagues. I think that's more
more of a powerful sort of evidence that
you are sent by God. No, that's not
that's not that's not clear proof. You
see what you're just doing. I have
respect. You're looking for anything
just to not accept Prophet Muhammad. You
made up your own criteria for what is a
miracle, what is not. Okay. But the
Bible, the criteria he gives clearly
doesn't say what you just said. So where
do you get that criteria from?
I just think I just think if God sent a
prophet, he would make it clear to to
people that he is truly sent by the the
God. So can someone split the moon?
Sorry. Can someone divide the moon, spit
the moon? Uh, no. But it just sounds
very like a fantasy. Fantasy. What about
spilling the water at the sea? It's it's
it's a miracle, right? The miracle that
was fantastic. I see.
But where was the the witnesses of the
uh the spitting of the moon compared to
the whole Israelite nation viewed and
saw the the the sea split? Different
different to saying later, oh, he split
the moon. like a sounds it sounds like a
off comment. What do you mean off
comment? I don't know. I don't know what
you mean. Moses Moses all of Why are you
not happy with
it's not as effective as saying the the
Israel are you Jewish originally or
something? No, he's okay. You know why
you just why you doing exactly what
Allah said about the Jewish people in
the Quran. When the prophet Muhammad
came with the miracle, they start making
their own miracle conditions for their
own miracles. So Allah said okay if is
the case how come you rejected the
miracle of Moses. Okay now the point
here is that is divine split the moon is
a miracle or not. But who saw this
movie? His companions that his
companions his companions. Yes. Okay.
What is the earliest manuscript of the
of the Torah?
Uh we have the desert. How many years
after Moses?
Maybe must have been thousands. Nearly
1,000 years. So the people that told us
that Moses divide the moon came 1,000
years after Moses. They never saw it.
Why you accepting it?
The sea. Sorry about so so that was why
there between for example imagine
someone says Hitler does such and such.
Okay. And he came after Hitler. He came
500 years after Hitler. We have to we
have to have a proof. So now you have a
the earliest record for Moses dividing
the sea is 1,000 years after Moses. You
accept it even though no one saw it. I
accept by by faith. Yes. By faith. I
accept it. Oh, so you accept it. It's
not about who saw it. It's about faith.
Now it's not a good point because it's
not about faith only. It's about proof.
Cuz it's called blind faith. Yeah. But
but you see it's called blind faith.
It's about proofs. It's not about cuz
cuz what is different between a Hindu
now and a Buddhist that's what that's
what differentiate Islam in a religion
Islam is not based upon I had a dream
prophet Muhammad came to me in the Ali
way but Muhammad saw places an angel
wrote down everything and it's the same
sort of there's no evidence that that is
divine revelation
there's no evidence that is divine
revelation we have to take Muhammad's
word that it's uh is is from God. No, it
is because if you go to the Quran, but
how do we know it? That's a good point.
So go to the Quran and that's the beauty
of Islam. Again, the Quran firstly, if
you compare the Quran and the the New
Testament, especially as a Christian,
firstly to know this book is from God or
not, we have to have the claim. You with
me? We have to have the claim. Imagine I
wrote a book and I never made a claim
this book from God.
Is it logical rational for someone to
come after me and make a claim on my
behalf? Even though myself I never made
a claim my books from God. Is it logical
for someone to make a claim on my
behalf? My behalf that my books from God
even though I never made that claim.
Uh it's not okay. Okay. Is is Luke and
is the New Testament from God? Uh yes.
Inspired. Yes. Okay. Show me Mark, Luke,
Matthew, John. They claim it's by God.
They they they claim they claim Christ
is God. Yes. No, they ask they claim cuz
I can I can claim a chicken is flying.
But whoa. Okay. Make it from God. Who
has the claim? Show me the claim
firstly. Step by step. First they ask
look at the claim cuz now imagine like I
said you bring me a newspaper from the
mirror and you said to me is this from
God? I'm going to have to say the first
thing does he claim from God? does not
claim. There's no need for me to verify
it. The claim is not even there. If it
claims, then we move on to the next step
to look into it in detail. But they are
saying that Christ claims to be God.
That's the difference. They're not
saying my my uh book is inspired by God.
Christ. They're speaking about God. Is a
Christ God. You believe Christ God. They
they speak about Christ and they say
Christ believed he was God. Okay. So
there so the school these are first uh
firstirhand testimonies witnesses.
They're witnesses of of Christ. Go Luke
1. Go to Luke
1:1. Clearly, you don't know your
gospel. Go to Luke 1:1. If you go to
Luke 1:1, I'm going to quote from the
top of my head. Luke 1:1. He says, "It
seems to me, it seems to me what there's
many people have
written gospels." Yeah. Yes. Step by
step. So, it seems good to me to write
an account. Is it because it was
inspired? No. Because eyewitnesses
passed down narration to him. So he's
not in the first century. No, he's not
the first hand. No, he's not. He never
saw it. People told him. But Luke in the
first century had access to witnesses of
So he was an eyewitness. He was with and
amongst the apostles. Was he eyewitness?
Uh Luke specifically was not. But John
was a even John is not. But we can go to
John. Same thing. John was a no no.
There's difference between John the
apostle or the the disciple and John who
wrote the John Bible. Here we go. Look
at you. Many have undertaken. So he
shows us what by Luke's statement. There
were many people have written the
gospels. Many people. Yes. Yes. Which
Christians outside accept anymore. Yes.
Even though early Christians accept it.
Yeah. So have have undertaken to draw up
an account of the things that have been
fulfilled among us just as they were
handed down to us to us. Yes. By those
who from the first were eyewitnesses and
the servant of the word with this in
mind. So he's making it clear that he
was not eyewitness. So he was not
inspired by God. So now go back to the
point again. Can you show me clearly
with Luke or Mark and Matthew John? They
were inspired by God. I can help you.
Matthew was an apostle. Show me when
Matthew said he was inspired by God.
Matthew was actually the apostle. He
claims to be the apostle. Let me just
make a claim. Show me where he said he
was inspired by God.
We're talking about eyewitnesses of the
actual person of Christ. I am the I saw
him. I was taught by him for 3 years.
Eyewitnesses. If if I met Jesus
eyewitness no he was I knew him. If I
doesn't mean he was inspired. You know
what inspired means? Being God inspired
him. Revelation. So revelation. If I if
I if I witness the revelation is Christ
number one. No, no, it's not. So, okay.
The revelation was a Christ. Yes. Okay.
So, number one. Yes. So, would they got
the information? We There are certain
things that Matthew and Paul said about
Jesus and other things which never told
them where they got it from.
Sorry. Say that again. Sorry. If you
read the Bible, the New Testament
clearly shows you there's a
red writing text here that shows you
that this Jes. Yes. And there's other
wording which is purely from Matthew.
Yes. So where Matthew got it from where?
His own speech. Where he got it from?
Well, Matthew the the words of Christ
were his interpret his uh uh commentary
etc. So his commentary was inspired. His
his commentary is inspired because show
me what he says that
that's the belief of the church that
he's his commentary. So is it believed
without proof? Look the Quran. the Quran
clearly the most beneficent to the
Quran that's his claim yet I'm saying
first I'm not saying because he claimed
it it must be true I'm not saying that
but we have to have the claim first we
claim this the church claims to have
authority that's to say this is
scripture this is not scripture show me
where Jesus said the church inspired by
God uh you are upon Peter you are you
are Peter and on this rock I will build
my church. The gates of hell will not my
church no churches cuz wait my church
the gates of hell will not prevail
against it where whatsoever you bind on
earth I will bound in which church or
Catholic church
Catholic okay if I bring the Protestant
no it's not would it but that's a
different debate so which church no it's
not a different debate Catholic so will
Jesus because Catholic is not the first
sex se the first sect is Nazarene that's
you don't know why you don't know
apostolic churches are the Catholic and
No, no, no. There's a Nazarene and
Ebonite. Nazarene and Ebonite. They're
not part of the church. Nazariz was the
first sect. They were the first sect and
they say same thing about you apostolic
church. No, founded by who? Apostle St.
Peter. But that's the reason St. Peter
went to Rome. You're not getting the
point here. And he was crucif crucified
upside down in Rome and he founded a
church. Peter. But that's what I'm
saying. You have a Christian your own
groups claiming the same thing. You see
how you struggling? I'm talking about
I'm talking about look at Muslim. Allah
said clear the Quran from the from him.
Christian he claimed that they were
inspired by God but you making the claim
on their behalf. But you still haven't
showed them no evidence. The evidence
you see you know the Christians who are
watching us sorry the Christians who are
watching us they say yes he's been fair
cuz the first thing we have look we have
to look at the claim. If you never claim
to be the strongest person I'm not going
to come challenge you because you never
made a claim. You understand? So firstly
you said the church makes the claim that
they have church the church the church
of the Coptic the church of the the
Catholic the Catholic who said they have
criteria because the Copic they said
they're more close to you they're more
than Jesus they were they're one they're
one church they're not one church no the
orthodox Catholic church we were we were
one they were one even the church
fathers had different for
1,53 years they they might have
differences on minor bits not their
basic theology in the trinity etc. Can
you tell us what was the what was the
purpose of the council of Nika if they
if they all of them had a minor
differences so what was the purpose
because they're heretics and they had to
be excommunicated from church who gave
but they were church as well claim to
follow Jesus because they they maintain
the apostolic tradition of the the the
apostles no
but they make a claim that Paul clearly
made distinction between Jesus and the
father you say they are one so the other
ones who clearly are using Paul's
teaching You made him as a heretic.
That's their interpretation. They're
going to say you interpretation too. So,
so who has your authority?
That's what I'm saying. All right. I
think the question should be where is
your distinct
clearcut unambiguous proof that it's
your church, not theirs?
I don't know what church you're
referring to. Sorry. No, the church that
you referred to. So, the text
historically speaking, they are they are
the churches founded by the apostles.
Yeah, but I'm saying the church you
referred to by way of the text. How is
it? It's your church. You're a Coptic,
correct? Churches. Yeah. So he You
believe he's a heretic? There were one
church. Um No, no, church. Not a heretic
or not. Heretic or not? Um
and you were lying when there was no one
here. Christian, they're different.
They're different in Isra. You just told
me the heretic. You just ask the
heretic. Some of the some of the some of
the uh the teachings of Anyway, anyway,
let's go back to Quran. Yeah. Minor
differences as well. It's not minor
differences. No, it's not. It's not like
the Coptic Coptic Coptic Coptic. They
believe Christ is God. They believe in
the church. No, they distinguish between
them. You pray through Mary. They
believe as a heretic. You pray through
Mary. No, they don't. No, they don't.
That's a lie. Protestant Protestant.
No, no, no. Protestant. Protestant
intercession. Protestant. I I don't care
what they're Protestants. But
Protestants are Christian B. Shall I
call Bob for you to debate Bob as well?
10,00
anyway council of na divinity divinity
that's a big so that is a big topic and
you had to use you had to use who you
had to use authority to force other
people you did not use the the it's
apostolic authority the authority given
given by Christ through you apostolic
authority maintain
maintaining the traditions of the
apostles and the apostolic deposit of
faith that is where The authority comes
from it comes from Jesus Christ himself
through St. Peter who died at Rome
established a church and that same
church that we see 2,000 years later
again 2,000 years again he's the same
church he doesn't believe everything you
believe in and you believe he's a
heretic they once they once were part of
our church and they they left are they
heretic or not they left the church on
minor details I don't know if the church
you'd have to look if you look you'd
have to look at the doctrine so which
church is correct their church or your
church the Catholic church is correct
but What about you details? What's the
minor detail? Look, look, diverting.
Clearly, he doesn't know what he's
talking about. I have respect. Clearly,
he doesn't know the history of
Christianity. Clearly, he doesn't know.
I know the history of 400 years later,
they went they went away. Um, but on
their left,
there's even there's Judeaic Christians.
But why how's that how's that an
argument against the argument? Sorry,
they were misguided. But on on my But
they believe you're misguided, too. They
believe you're not following the true
teaching of Jesus. They are using the
same scripture you're using. Baba,
that's why my brother Jamal told you a
good question. Interpret scripture.
That's why. So there's no clical
distinction criteria. There is the
authority given to the Catholic church.
Okay. Where's that? Okay. Where Jesus
said the Catholic church are the
authority. Show me the wording. You you
are Peter and upon this rock I will
build my church. Catholic is a Catholic
church because church is Well, that's
just the name. No, no. Church is a
general name can apply to Protestant
church. Catholic church. No, no, no, no.
Catholic church. Catholic means
universal and the church was won for
1,500. You making your own claim anyway.
But anyway, let's go back to the point.
Show me where the the rights of the
Bible claim to be inspired by God. Clear
cut. Cuz they said they were inspired.
Then you tell me the church made a claim
for them. And you told me no one is
allowed to make claim for someone
else. Anyway, the Quran clear the Quran.
The miracle of the Quran. We have the
miracle to go back to Quran because
you're going all over the place. The
miracle of the Quran, the Quran does not
just make claim. No, it goes further.
The Quran cla says if you are in doubt,
if you are in doubt about this book,
then bring something like it. For Allah,
our challenge in home to understand the
challenge, you have to look back at
Jesus' lifetime as well. Jesus lifetime,
one of his miracle, it was to bring dead
people to life and to heal the people.
Yes. Why? Because at that region the
Greeks and the Romans were known for
medicine. Okay? They were very good at
medicine. So when they saw Jesus
bringing dead people to life, they knew
this beyond medicine, beyond human
capacity. Moses time, the Egyptian, they
were good at magic. So Allah gave a
miracle to Moses. It seems like magic,
but they knew it's beyond magic. Prophet
Muhammad's
time they were very good at Arabic
language speaking eloquency poetry and
everything literally they had no books
before that literally they used to
memorize thousands of lines of poems and
on the spot they were they used to
challenge one another when prophet
Muhammad brought the Quran and he
challenged them and you know remember if
someone is a liar someone is a liar and
he knows what he's bringing is just made
up and he knows there's people bitter
than him he will never come out and
start challenging everyone Do you
believe the Let me finish. People
to me, do I believe I fly? Something
joking. Anyway, let me finish.
So long. I believe you got bad jokes.
Anyway, you know, thank you very much
for that. He will use my jokes after.
No, no, no. I said anyway to move on. So
Allah challenge challenge the people to
bring something like it many times. Then
Allah said in the Quran, no one is able
to bring the challenge. One of the
miracle of the Quran as well that Allah
said we have made Quran easy to be
memorized. Okay. So this statement Allah
never said it's for the Arabs is a
general statement. This Quran is been
made easy to be memorized. It's
impossible for someone to live 1,400
years ago in the middle of nowhere to
make this statement. And how finishing
go.
Yeah. So and now we can go to Africa,
Europe, Asia. The Muslims that don't
speak Arabic language. Listen carefully.
Muslims don't speak Arabic language.
They memorize the Quran word for word
and letter for letter. Okay? It's like
all of us here, we have we memorize the
book in Chinese. But guess what? We
don't even speak
Chinese. What? You don't even speak
Chinese. And even the way you you read
the book in Chinese so perfectly. But
when you speak Chinese, even if you do
speak, you make mistakes with the Quran.
Likewise, the miracle that Allah
preserve it, you can put in say likewise
the prophecies in the Quran. Likewise,
many many so likewise the prophecy where
Allah said, "Oh, Muhammad, your name has
been mentioned in previous scripture."
You can go to Isaiah. Same thing. So
this book, yeah, but to be honest, I use
Isaiah. Isaiah is the strongest one.
They cannot run away from it. So that's
the beauty of the Quran. just make claim
even if you know Arabic language no one
in the history speaks the Quranic style
but that doesn't mean it's divine who
knows the future in detail
who knows the future in detail god god
so if someone tell us the things in in
detail about future and it's coming to
us according to is a prophet of god
no not not necessarily get the passage
get the passage
Yeah. Okay. Please read it for his
friend. Please. No. Read it. No. No.
Read it. Because right what he's doing,
he's going to trade now. What he's going
to end up doing, you're going to end up
going against your own Bible for the
sake of rejecting Prophet Muhammad. And
mark my
words. Get it for us. The Bible. We're
going to use the Bible as a criteria to
know you. My
[Music]
brother, excuse me. Can you read it for
us? Stop talking like
a
nice bring the passage, please. Can you
read it? Thank you very much. Yeah.
Okay, here in Deutronomy, it tells us
how to know true prophet. It says here
uh
18:18. Uh here we go. 1818. Oh no, that
is not 188. It's the other one.
Uh the nation would appear. The Lord has
Lord God will raise up among you first.
You must listen. The Lord will send you.
Okay. Must have a word. But if you Okay.
I myself will call to account and not
listen to my words. But uh uh to my word
that the prophet speaks in my name.
You're looking just for the criteria of
being Yeah. Which one? The prophecy of
Yeah. The word. The word. Not the the to
know the prophets of God. No, no, no.
The word here. I'm here. But a prophet
who pre speak in my name anything that I
have no command or a prophet who speaks
in the name. How can we know this the
one? Yes. 18 1822.
or uh
yeah uh uh 21. You might say to
yourselves, how can we know when a
message has not been spoken by the Lord?
If a if what a prophet proclaims in the
name of the Lord does not take place or
come true, that is a message of the Lord
has not spoken. The prophet has spoken
wrongly. Okay? So do not be alm. So here
if a prophet speaks in the name of God
does not come to pass if the prophet
speaks in the name of God does not come
to pass it's not the word of God but if
it comes to pass is the word of God so I
you agree with it but thank you very
much so I just show you prophet Muhammad
in the Quran not prophet Muhammad Allah
through the Quran prophesies about many
things which come to pass okay according
to the criteria in your Bible he's a
true prophet do you accept it or not
Well, I don't accept it. Uh, so that
criteria is wrong. The criteria is
right, but it's not
exclusively. It means that's a sign that
he is a prophet. But, uh, even a liar
can uh deceive people and it can come to
to be true eventually. But there are no
criteria then. No, it's correct. But
there's no contradiction. If if a liar
can prophesize and come to pass because
of course a li prophesize but the Bible
says it will not come to pass. It will
not come to pass. That's what he says.
But but but Christianity came to pass.
Look what you talking about? That's a
confusing first. I'm telling you that
criteria is your own book.
You understand? Clearly that's what I'm
saying. You know what he just did
happened to me 5 years ago over. I was
speaking to Jewish two Jewish guys.
Yeah. And the same thing they had to do.
They had to go against their own Bible
for the sake of accepting Prophet
Muhammad. where you could have just said
say listen yes it's a criteria but but
let me look more into it okay but don't
start saying it's a criteria but clearly
it's a criteria you know I do accept
it's one of the criteria it's not the
only criteria you understand I do accept
it a false prophet he will mix the truth
with a falsehood but when you look to
prophet
Muhammad for example you know about
Isaiah
42 you see how long you've been going
church maybe like a year and a half even
if you go for 15 years they will never
tell you about Isaiah 42 because Isaiah
42 speaks about prophets even the rabbis
they differed who is that prophet so in
Isaiah 42 if you take it out brother and
read it but that one say you have the
spirit of God yeah the revelation called
spirit anyway but in the Quran says but
it can't be him because he's saying that
yeah because the Quran Allah referred to
Allah referred to the to the revelation
is a spirit because is a spirit of the
our lives you know but This is why he
says yes. He said if you can let me read
it
here.
Okay. The servant of the Lord. He are my
servants whom I uphold. My chosen one in
whom I delight. I will pour my spirit on
him and he will bring justice to the
nations. To show you they play with
words. If you go to the Hebrew means the
Gentiles cuz the nations could be
everyone but Gentiles is the non-Jew.
You see King James, he mentioned the
Gentiles. And likewise, if you go to
Hebrew, he said the Gentiles, the
non-Jews. Yeah. So, uh let us go carry
on. So, he will not he will not shout or
cry out or raise his voice in the
street. A bruise read. He will not break
and
sm and do more research about it. Yeah.
He says he has sing to the Lord a new
song, his praise from the ends of the
earth. Here if you go to the Hebrew mean
a new
law and all the prophets after Mos Moses
came to fulfill the Mosaic law. He
didn't come with a new law. The only
prophet that came with a new law.
Prophet Muhammad. Yeah. He says let the
witness and his sons raise their voices.
Let the the settlements where Keda lives
rejoice. Who was
Keda? Who was Keda? Okay. If you go to
Genesis 25:13, he said these the names
of the sons of Ishmael according to
their generation. The firstborn of
Ishmael is Nabayot. The second one is
Kedar. So tell me the prophets you tell
me which prophet came from the lineage
of Kedar who came and he made the people
rejoice people of Keda rejoice. Tell me
which one. There's more to it. You can
check it out after more to it. And even
he says
let sah mountain of silah mountain of
silah I want medina literally the
mountain of silah right next to the
mosque of the prophet Muhammad wasallam
you see so and this by the way who used
it was one of the rabbis he used this he
was a rabbi at the time prophet Muhammad
wasallam afterwards he used it even some
scholars mention the the those who
believe in prophet Muhammad from the
Jewish rabbis at the time prophet
Muhammad wasallam used this passage to
prove is the prophet Muhammad wasallam
and there's another go sorry but he's
saying that I'll put my spirit on him
yeah you agree with that one yeah you
know spirit do you agree that Muhammad
had the spirit of God yeah he gave
revelation that's what he means
revelation is refer to a
spirit is known revelation of god
okay there prophet Muhammad explained
this to us in the Quran there there are
some people they are alive but they are
dead why because they don't have the
spirit of god what is spirit of god is
revelation cuz when you know your
purpose of life and you worship God, you
have that spirit of God doesn't mean
spirit of God here means the revelation
which God send down like a spirit give
us the true meaning of
life and you can go backh
yeah Gabriel is spiritual
so you can help
me Allah holy
spirit that's
good my spirit Yeah.
[Music]
Yeah. But
Does that mean that they all ritual? So
here the verse let me
get Allah says about the
Quran the verse which is verse number
193 the chapter
what's the chapter let me do you have
the Quran
no no the chapter name the surah
Which one?
Sorry, brother.
What's the what's the point? What do you
think about what he said about
lie? That was an
indication. Yeah, cuz I know the verse.
I know the chapter. I've been holding
many things.
My
brother knowber.
[Music]
What happened to your leg? No, it's not
my leg. I have vertigo. Okay. Okay.
Yeah. So, I start feeling losing balance
and dizziness.
Yeah. I mean, today I was getting it
very bad in the morning.
Alhamdulillah. Sometimes I don't have it
at all.
So he's going to stop talking.
How are you, brother? You
ready? There you go.
There we go. Very this revelation from
the Lord of the world. He came down the
spirit of faith. Okay. the truth of the
spirit. Okay. To their to your heart. I
mean the translation is not really doing
justified to your heart. Okay. Arabic
with Arabic language. You speak about
the
Quran.
Okay. Yeah. That is the verse which
Quran mean and Allah said another verse
Allah
said Allah send down upon
you. So Allah said the Quran came with
and prophet Muhammad said came down with
the Quran. So has many names trustworthy
spirits the holy
spirit the verse I forgot
the no. Okay. When treason was
u made by the spirit of Quran.
No it was not made by spirit. It was
spirit.
Sorry. It was it was spirit who was
blowing. So Allah gave the spirit that
which Allah created for Isa and Isa blow
it blow it into the the sleep of
Mary.
Our
spirit smoking.
This one, there's other one as well. But
this one is Yeah. All our spreads and he
testify to the truth. Yes. This as well.
And there's other one as well. It's a So
did Allah give Gabriel the spirit to
give it to Jesus? That which Allah
created. Yeah. To blow it into. So the
spiritual created there.
Okay. Yeah. I mean according to
Christians that Gabriel came up on me.
Correct. To receive the good news. No.
To to get pregnant. Is it just like the
teller died? He said he said he said he
said he said I do remember. He said not
the word but he covered her like a dove.
Yeah. Yeah. He kept up on her.
You believe Jesus to be God? Oh yes sir.
You know. So is the father fully God?
Yes. How many god do you have so far? Is
the father still god? Yes. One god. Yes.
So are we in need of another god or the
father is sufficient to be god by
himself?
I know they believe forh I know you
don't believe but this is going. You
know the believer. No no no. I know you
don't believe. I'm about to say. Okay.
Just go back. If Allah decided to come
and
kill that make two. That's
contradiction. That's a paradox cuz
human are created and God is uncreated.
Human are imperfect. God is perfect. You
are differentiating between what God is
and what God does. God does whatever he
wishes. What God is does not change his
nature. That's why in Malachi it says I
the Lord do not change. Exactly. If if
God become human, he changes nature. So
for because if you accept and of course
all of us will accept God is perfect all
the time. Correct. It's it's his spirit
that's perfect.
God's spirit. What about God himself? Is
he perfect? Yes. All of God. All of God
is perfect. So God is perfect. It's like
me saying God has a divine nature and
divine nature has obviously a
measurement of what he should be. One of
is he has to be perfect. He can't commit
any sins. He can't be anything. No. Talk
about good. Good God. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Good. Is he perfect? But my answer is
this. If Allah
decides Allah is God perfect? Yes. So if
all the time Yes. So if he becomes human
yes human are perfect or imperfect
has he committed a sin no human are
ignorant Jesus didn't know the hour
Jesus he didn't know many things in the
Bible said Jesus had to learn so if God
perfect in knowledge is illogical
irrational impossible for someone to
have a perfect knowledge then he learns
because he already has knowledge why
he's done he's not he's done something
he already knows I understand that's why
I'm showing you your Christian's
argument about God can't do everything
because you don't understand and you
have no differentiate between what God
is and what god does. When you
understand these two concepts,
everything will become clear to you and
you'll be able to refute atheist and the
philosophers who come with a question if
God is able to do everything. Can he
create another god? Because when you
when you differentiate between what God
does and what God is, alhamdulillah,
that's why Islam is able to defeat
atheism. That's why the the only
religion that is fighting against
atheism and defeating atheism is Islam,
not Christianity.
So you're saying Jesus can't be perfect
because he doesn't fit the requirement
of God. Jesus himself said he doesn't
know the hour. No, I'm saying not me.
Yeah. I'm saying the requirement to be
perfect, you have to have all the
characteristic to be God. No. When you
say God is perfect, we mean perfect in
everything. Correct. I mean, for
example, even if someone doesn't have
knowledge, is that person still perfect?
That's not God. You can't say it's
perfect everything. Is God perfect
everything?
So if God is perfect in everything.
Yeah. But if you if he we're claiming
that he has a fully human nature. No.
No. I'm not talking about Jesus about as
God. I'm talking of God. God as soon as
he becomes imperfect. He's no longer
God. He's not imperfect. It's it's just
a fully human nature. To to to have a
fully human nature is to limit yourself
in knowledge. For example, what do you
mean limit himself? to to limit to limit
uh to become fully human is to limit for
example your your ability your your
capacity for uh knowledge. No. What do
you mean limit become ignorant or what
do you mean? When you say limit he
became ignorant or he just said you know
what because remember he never say I
know the hour but I don't want to say
it. No he said no one knows the hour.
That's Mark 13:32. He said no one knows
the hour not even the angels in the
heaven nor the son but only the father.
And you believe Jesus as God, not as
human being, Jesus as God. Is it the
father or the son? Son. Son. So Jesus
said only the father. So he's negated
the knowledge of the Allah from himself
as as God and as human because they have
different roles. There are different
roles in the godhead. That the father
has a different role to the son. Uh the
son has a different role to the holy
spirit. Otherwise there would be no
there would be no distinction.
Otherwise, who should dictate to who who
okay God has no beginning?
Does he have is eternal beetting of the
son? Does he have a person? Does God
have a perfect authority? Yes. Can
anyone dictate to God what to do? Okay.
So, if Jesus is God, how come the father
is dictating to him what to do? He he
willingly submits. You just told me no.
Now you're going to justify it. The son
the son submits completely and
wholeheartedly to the father. But God
does not submit to no one. Exactly. So
how can it's submission to himself?
You're submitting to someone who submits
to Allah. You're you're using your our
human rationale to explain divine. So
how are we going to use our sorry we're
going to use our to understand as long
as it does not contradict our rational.
What about in the book of Corinthians
where the father will be sitting in one
given place and then Jesus will come and
be subordinate to the father. sub to the
father even judgement and sub be
subordinate to the father because the
Christian always say all authority is
given to the son yeah but the authority
was given does anyone sorry does anyone
give something to god
does god have authority all the time or
someone gave him authority
no one gave he gave him authority so
Jesus cannot be the only someone gave
authority to him because he's a prophet
if you look at it makes no sense he's a
prophet and even the early Christians
I don't I wouldn't say that. I wouldn't
say Have you read the book about lots of
Christianities? Yeah. Lots of
Christianities. You see,
I've you have no knowledge about
Christian Christian history cuz if you
read many books even by the Christian
scholars, they would tell you there was
many Christian not many there were
Christian sects. But do you read do you
read you know have you read the church
fathers for example Ignatius Irenaeus um
uh all of these church poly these are
these are followers of the apostles who
believe this doctrine about the doctrine
about the the trinity. Are we suggesting
that in the space of one generation the
the the doctrine of the trinity is so
distorted from the original teaching
that the the the the initial church
completely failed to transmit this
doctrine. What was the part of Nia? You
had to use a force for people to accept
your tweet. What? Hang on. This is not
if it was a clear. Yeah, you had to use
the king. What was the argument? What
was the purpose of council na? That will
take you to the the council of na came
in what year? Sorry. 300 something. 300
years. Why? So in that so in the first
2nd uh third century that's three
centuries they maintain the apostolic
tradition and faith. No, no, no. And the
council of Nia just say what was Nyer?
What was the purpose of Nia? What was
it? Tell us. Because there were there
were people distorting the truth about
Christ. What was the what was their
arguments? It's called aranism.
Aras from the one of the
groups. Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
The argument. The answer is this. This
is very important. I know. You had a
group of people that didn't believe
Jesus was divine. And you had a group of
people 300. No. No. There were many
groups. There was some group that
believe it was divine, but he was lesser
than the father. Yeah. 300 years later.
That's what that's what I'm saying.
There were many groups. Where did they
get that from? 300 years later, they
adapted and misunderstood the original
teachings of the apostles. What if it
was the other way around? They're the
ones that were on the other guys
elevated in the religion because we can
read that the church fathers, the
apostles, and there's an unbroken chain
of church fathers too. This is the thing
because you've been you've been
indoctrinated read the church by the
side that are not good for his divinity.
You have not read
anti let's go back to no you haven't
read his word. So please you haven't
even they affirm the truth. No but
before sorry to go back to the main
point. Yeah. You know what you're not
doing? Not you, him especially. Exactly
what Allah taught us in the Quran that
the Christians and the Jews took their
rabbis and the church fathers and the
priests gods besides Allah. Yes. Cuz
clearly you can see in the Bible there's
many clear passages which clearly
indicate Jesus cannot be God. But still
you taking the church fathers
explanation and this sorry step by step.
When I ask you about something when I
say is God perfect straight away you say
yes. So that is Jesus God. Uh no but but
but so God there's no back with God
human nature divine nature. Okay. Which
which which part of Jesus was God and
which part of him was divine? So in the
incarnation he becomes fully human. Yes.
But eternally he's begget uh begotten by
the father. That's my question. Which
part of Jesus was God? Which part of him
was divine? Jesus was walking the
street. You said he was he was divine
and and human at the same time. Human
nature. Okay. So in the Bible said he
became when you became something mean
you transform you incarnate you change
incarnation. Okay. Incarnation. Okay. In
the Bible in the Old Testament Jacob
said to God oh God the heavens the
heavens cannot contain you. The heavens
cannot contain you let alone my temple.
Now let me ask you I don't want to
mention the name of his mother because
I'm just showing it as
for So are you saying the vagina of his
mother was bigger than the the temple of
Jacob? This is why we believe in her
perpetual virginity and purity because
to be a perfect vessel for God. Now they
ask you that no God is bigger than the
universe. Correct. Yes. So when he had
to go inside the woman private part he
had to change. He had to become smaller
otherwise he cannot fit in. So he
changed. He Yeah. He he limited he he
became man. But in the Bible we said God
does not change.
His nature doesn't change. His nature to
be his nature to become does not change.
Is it not his nature? Sorry. Is it not
his nature to become the Is it not his
nature to be the greatest all the time?
Is it not his nature to be the greatest
all the time? The greatest all the time.
That's why you know one point if you
read the he remained he remained great
even as a human private part he was a he
was a perfect you have you have my he
was a perfect human being yes no he was
not perfect human being did was he
perfect knowledge perfect knowledge did
Jesus sin was he yeah he did according
to you believe he did yeah because he he
was a racist Islam I don't know about no
Islam I don't believe he sin because
prophet Muhammad never sinned he had
shortcomings yes so in Islam did Jesus
sin Muhammad never sin doesn't make him
god prophet Muhammad never sin he never
sinned No, they have shortcomings.
There's a between shortcomings and a
sins. Prophet Muhammad is the definition
of sin. No, shortcomings is not a sin.
It's not. It's not sin. When you obey
God intentionally. Okay. Shortcom. For
example, you for example, regardless how
much you worship God, you will never be
able to repay back God for his
blessings. Correct.
Yeah. So now, regardless how much you
try, you're always going to fall into
shortcomings. Doesn't mean you're
disobeying God. Even though you tried to
worship God, but so what you do in
Islam, we have the concept of seeking
forgiveness. That's why in the Quran,
Allah told Prophet Muhammad to seek
forgiveness cuz seeking forgiveness all
the time doesn't necessitate you
committing a sin. And the proof for this
in the prayer when we pray as a Muslims
after finishing the prayer, we
say, we seek Allah forgiveness. Even
though we were not doing haram, we were
praying. Why we seek forgiveness?
Because we know regardless how much we
worship Allah, we will never be able to
repay back Allah for his bless. However,
according to your belief, yes, he did
sin because he was a racist to a woman.
Who? Who? The Canonites. Oh, I don't
know where you're afraid. Okay. The
woman, she came to to our prophet. I
don't believe this, by the way. They
they believe it. Okay. So, she came to
Jesus and his disciple. Her daughter had
a demon possessed by demon.
So, who you saying,
bro? So, she came to the to to Jesus and
his followers and they she was begging
him for help.
The man that you know tried to portray
for us is all loving. He cares about
everyone. He didn't want to help her. Do
you know who had to push him to help
her? His disciple. Do you know why? He
said because she keeps following us. He
looks like a He looks like humiliation.
So Jesus said to her, I have not been
sent to the lost I have only been sent
to the lost house sheep of Israel. Okay.
But she was a canite. Yeah. And he's
like, it's not be fitting to give a dog
the bread to the dogs. Yeah. So he
compared the covenant was with the Jews.
Yes. So he compared you believe that. So
we come to it. Will you compare a dog?
The dogs were pagans. Yes. You what? You
agree with paganism? No, I don't call
pagan a dog. You you agree with a pagan?
Yes. No, but I can't call pagan a dog.
Just because he's a pagan. He's a
disbeliever. You know, you talk about
the woman. No, outside the covenant
between God and and
and refer to a pagan as a dog. He's a
disbeliever. Yes. That was the phrase
that they used at the time. It's not the
term dog. It's not it's not but finish
the scripture. Let's not let's not
butcher. No, I'm good. Let's let's let's
look at how it ends. It says it's not
fitted to give dogs what is the comfort
of the the bread. And she in all
humility said even the dogs can eat
and he saw her faith and that is why uh
Jesus allowed all Gentiles. Yeah. So the
example of this I stop you then I give
you cake. That's why he did he humiliate
her front of everyone then he helped
her. Compare this talking about he's
talking about pagan nations which
compare this. Do you agree paganism is
is not from God? Evil disgusting.
Disgusting evil. Christ is
saying they don't deserve to be saved
but I will sacrifice my life. Allah told
us they save everyone. You see Muhammad
Muhammad helped people even if they're
not Muslims he helped them and he told
us we believe Christ died for pagans who
don't deserve like us. He never died for
pagans cuz they have to believe. He died
for all humanity. So he died for a pagan
so the pagan will go to paradise. For
all humanity. Yes. So pagan go to
paradise. He died that we they might
accept Christ. Ah, so they have to
accept him. There's a condition. Don't
say that for the pagans. He died for
them as long they believe in him.
There's a condition. There's a
condition. Of course. So is it all
loving? Of course it in Islam. You don't
believe you have. No. No. Is it all
loving? You have to follow God's
commandments. Is it all loving? Yes. So
if it's all loving, it's unconditional.
It's not. It's unconditional love. But
we have to accept it and and follow God.
It's a condition in in in Islam.
That's not Islam. There's no condition.
You don't believe. You said there's no
there's no condition. You claim there's
no condition, but you just contradicted
yourself. You said there's a condition.
You have to believe
it. Anyway, anyway, anyway, I would say
something compare description of the
Quran about God and about Christianity.
In the Quran, Allah
said,
"Allah, Allah is the only one deserves
to be worshiped
alone." The ever living, the one who's
in charge of
everything. No, he doesn't tired,
doesn't
sleep. Whatever is in the heavens and
the earth and that is between them
belongs to him. Also in the Quran, Allah
describes him as alaz alim al karim.
Perfect attributes. When you come to
Christianity, you know this teaching,
you don't have to have a qualification
from Oxford University to understand the
Islamic uh uh foundation. Yes. When you
come to Christianity, you literally not
you have to be philosopher to accept
this nonsense. That's not true. See, all
of all of Europe were to Christianity
because they were all of them were
heavily influenced by Greek philosophy,
the Romans. But they were they were not
they were not they were not highly
people that's all of Europe converted to
Christianity because they never
Christianity. So God is perfect. God
does not change but God become a baby.
Someone changes nothing. But God is not
in need of no one. But God was because
he's teaching us humility. You
understand? Because humility so he he be
what angers himself contradicts himself
through humility. It's noting God.
That's what we're trying to say. Forget
it's Yes. Yes. Sorry.
Let me speak to you respect. You
were originally where I'm from. No,
originally what were we talking
originally? We're talking about why
Jesus cannot be God by utilizing our
sound intellect and scripture. What's
the the spirit talking about? It's not
it's not really interesting about I mean
it's not really important because if go
if God spirit or not is not going to
save you. What is going to save us first
is believe in God alone and following
his teaching. Okay, that's the most
important in the Bible and the Quran.
Same thing. The first commandment is
what? God, believe in one God and love
him. Okay, so let us talk about this
concept if you really believe in one god
or three gods. But not very I'm just
saying is that I haven't read the wrong
book to understand like theological
issue. No, it's not really that hard.
Sorry, not hard like it doesn't start
from the beginning. It starts from like
Allah is all merciful but then obviously
the chapters get shorter and shorter.
No, sorry. Just correct you on this
point because if you look to the Quran,
the way it starts is so perfect. Why the
first chapter? No, no, I know what you
mean. I'm just saying. No, let me just
give you this nice benefit. This nice
benefit you can learn from in the Quran
start
with praising
Allah his lordship showing that he
should be worshiped alone showing his
perfect names and attributes. Then he
goes on asking Allah subhana wa ta'ala
supplication. Then he goes on and he
speaks about uh three groups. Those who
want stray, those who have and Allah's
anger and those who uh uh are the guided
one. Yes. The next chapter he explains
to you. So all after this chapter all
the Quran is speaking in detail about
Allah's name attributes his lordship his
worship the supplication about the
stories between the evil one and the
good ones and the path of the evil ones
and the good ones. So next chapter is
Allah showing you the story of Ben is to
show you how they had the knowledge but
never act upon it. So, subhan Allah, the
Quranic way is so perfect how it's been
laid out.
Appreciate that. Okay.
You know what he said to me originally?
Everybody has a spirit to receive
revelation. I said, "Everybody has a
spirit to receive revelation." I didn't
I didn't say that everybody has spirit.
Allah gives the spirit to people without
revelation. You know, I said spirits
which Allah gave for is the revelation
and and we refer to to revelation as
spirit and that is in the Quran. In the
Quran, Allah
mention so every prophet has a
revelation of Allah. But why is Jesus
the only one referred to the spirit of
Allah and the word of Allah? No, the
Quran refer to Adam as the spirit of
Allah as well. The Quran already clarify
when the meaning because you know this
why it's very important to understand
the Arabic language for example Allah
subhana wa ta'ala mentioned that Adam
spirit as his spirit so in Arabic
language Allah attribute something to
himself something attributed not
something like it's part of him
something out of honor for example Allah
said about the camel which he gave one
of the prophet as a miracle so to
understand there was a small rock and he
divided the rock and the camel out of
it. Yes. So Allah
said the she came of Allah doesn't mean
that Allah all these camels were not
created by Allah. So when Allah
attributed Jesus the word Allah Allah
already mentions in the Quran
in the similitude of Jesus with Allah is
like Adam. Allah created from dust and
he said be and he was. So the word Allah
mean was created by the word Allah and
you have to be fair. Now if I bring any
clear
statement then I clarify what I meant.
Who you going to
take? Of course you're going to follow
my explanation of my clear statement. So
I it's an statement which Allah himself
clarified it clearly. So spirit was
created by Allah subhana wa tala. But
Adam I understand what you're saying.
Yeah. Every prophet or every human being
is given a spirit from Allah in some
sense according to no we have we have a
soul which Allah created or call them
spirits but if you talk about spiritual
revelation Allah send prophet Muhammad
sallaihi wasallam or Jesus or Moses or
other prophets and messengers and for
the people to have a good life the real
meaning of life to follow that
revelation which is referred to as
spirit maybe natural inclination that
naturally everyone have something within
us. You guys understand that the way
Allah portrays Jesus is a different way
of spirit of Allah in the world of
Allah. No, it doesn't. Cuz Allah
clarified this already. Like I said, I
said, "Bro, if you tell me something,
then you explain your statement." I
cannot go around and ask people what he
meant cuz you already clarified it. If I
keep doing it, shows me I'm I've been
dishonest cuz you yourself said, "No,
Shy, what I meant such and such." So in
the Quran already Allah clarified it
what he meant by the spirit and the word
of Allah.
So there's no space you know. So my
understand is there's no room. Everybody
has a split of Allah.
How do you get into that conclusion?
Because you said the everybody has the
inclination of Allah. No no no is not
the
fraination which Allah creates people
with. So naturally you don't have to
learn you don't have to be a Christian
or a Muslim to know you should not
oppress people
you know oppression is forbidden so it's
called fra you should you know that I
should believe in God and worship him
alone okay it's called you understand
this notification okay Allah created in
us so from an Islamic point of view what
exactly is the term
messiah so just for Jesus yeah yeah yeah
so mean to travel some is to travel
around that's what Jesus was doing
traveling or has been wiped they say
when he was young some something the
angel wipes over him does the Quran have
like a definition no it doesn't clearly
no it doesn't because Quran does not pay
attention in detail something which is
not really really important you know the
Quran pays Quran pays attention to that
which will save me like if I don't
believe in Jesus if I don't know the
meaning of Messiah but I I worship a cow
that will not benefit me knowing the
meaning of Messiah no it's not that it's
just that the reason is important
because no it's not he was the word
Messiah is gets used over law in the old
testament so Allah knows there's a a
conceptual veneration towards the coming
Messiah so obviously the Jews knew the
Messiah would come from my understanding
is the Messiah is very important even
though from understanding it's not as
important as the seal of the prophet
Muhammad
is a description of the Messiah because
obviously the Messiah is from the
Islamic point of view virgin rin
miraculous and you will come back as a
followup of Muhammad. What exactly is so
important the word Messiah? I guess
overused quite a lot in the Old
Testament. No, just have a look. And now
when you say what is important for
example in the Quran that Allah refer to
the we have to see if we can oh maybe
there meaning behind it the noon because
it was uh
John Jonah. Yeah. where he went from
Jonah. Yeah, he was he was eaten by the
whale. Okay. In the Quran, what I'm
saying when Allah gave that name to
Jesus, the scholar said in Arabic
language, sometimes he came from the
word, okay, he's been wiped over the
angel or he was traveling, but the most
important about Jesus is not because
he's called Msiah. The most important
why he came to teach. That's the most
important. That's why Jesus was not
focusing every single day to his
followers, you know why I'm called
Christ? Why I'm Messiah? not messiah. He
was focusing on what? Believing God,
following his teaching. So even
according to your book, Jesus did not
really pay, did not emphasize too much
why he's called messiah. No, it's not
that. I understand that. So why are we
going to waste time? Because the only
difference is that Moses doesn't call
himself the Messiah cuz he isn't the
Messiah. Abraham doesn't call him
Messiah because he is the Messiah. So my
understanding is if Jesus claims to be
the Messiah, he has to tick certain
boxes because Moses did miracles. He
said only one God and Jesus same thing
as well. But my understand is what word
but antichrist we call him as well. No,
but no. Yeah. doesn't make him special
as a Muslim like obviously if someone
was to become Muslim what is the
criteria that that is cuz obviously the
Jews are hearing this for the first time
like they knew the Messiah will come but
they don't expect this kind of Messiah
the Jesus like he's preaching so my
understanding is what were the boxes
that Jesus had to fill he did the
miracles like Moses he did the preaching
he was born out of father yeah but
that's I mean what do you mean you to
say I don't understand like you know I
mean like I have respect to you I think
we are really spending time on something
is not really that important. It's
important that you believe even if you
know the meaning of the messiah what it
means the messiah but you still believe
in three gods will not benefit you. It's
not that just the word. So which one is
going to going to pay attention to to
something is going to save you and
benefit you or something is lesser. Any
human being with a sound intellect is
going to focus on something which is
more important and which one is going to
save him in this life and the here
after. I'll tell you reason why I'm
okay. Tell me why telling you why go
because I just wanted to know Islamic
point of view when I hear from Muslim
it's very like face it like yeah he was
just a virgin yeah he had credentials to
provide it but Islam seemed to me just
another word that Allah just chose to
give it to make Jesus have this title
every prophet has a title to show
Allah's mercy Allah has like a specific
love for every prophet but the reason
I'm saying this sorry I'm
Yeah.
Now from a Christian theological point
of view, the Messiah is meant to die for
our sins because one of the first
criteria is Emanuel, God with us, the
spirits. And Emanuel born in Bethlehem.
One of the criterias in order to the
third is being. And then fourth, he will
be a transgression for our sins. Those
are the four criterias for the Messiah
in the Old Testament. And we go to the
New Testament. Jesus tells us that he's
coming for ransom many. But first, he's
comes with a lot of sheeps. When Jesus
is in the mount, one of the mountains
with James, Peter, and John, and he sees
uh Elijah or Moses. Yes. And he's
talking to them. But once he's finished,
Jesus told the disciples, "Do not tell
anybody until the son of man has been
risen from the dead." So we can see a
clarification that Jesus is emphasizing
something a bit more a natural cause
that will happen later on whilst
fulfilling from the old testament that
when Jesus dies resurrected you can see
the disciples have seen Jesus
transformed to the glowing you see look
to my hands look my done I'm still alive
now preach the gospel that is an
esquetology of understanding what Jesus
meant for us in the end of times but
wait give me a second then just give me
one
from an Islam point of view is a messiah
is just a miraculous statement that
Allah chose because he had two miracles
that other prophet did. He was born of a
virgin Mary miraculous other than he
done preaching Islam which the other
prophets have but every prophet has done
that but I just want to know what is the
purpose behind the meaning of Messiah
there has to be a check that's okay
Islamically Allah describes his messiah
as I've mentioned either because he was
traveling or the angel wiped over his
head anointed him so it's anointed him
or no wipe over his head yes so it's
just a description Allah describing him
with something which is was distinct
from him from other prophets like for
example Allah described Jonah the noon
yes so he gave him title that will
distinguish him from the other prophets
for example the name that was given to a
prophet by Allah is doesn't mean is God
now and you said about Jesus according
to Christian belief according to the old
testament the messiah that will not
leave until establish justice upon the
earth and we know Jesus never did that
so that's why there were many Jewish
people who said the messiah that
Christians believed in is not the
Messiah which in the Old Testament has
been prophesized about. Also, you said
that in the Old Testament is called
Emmanuel which is God with us or be
called Emanuel. We know historically his
mother his disciples never called Jesus
Emmanuel. Okay? Emanuel everlasting
father. If you believe Jesus everlasting
father, you're a heretic. Okay? So what
are you doing out of respect? You're
picking up a one word in here, few word
in there, three prophecy here, and
bringing it together, try to apply it on
Jesus. Okay? But to to go back to the
main point what you just did, you're
digressing from the the foundation. The
foundation is is to believe in one God.
Jesus died for your sins. Let us see if
this the foundation of Jesus teaching.
According to the Bible, when the young
boy came to Jesus, he said, "All right,
good master. What should I do to enhance
the kingdom of heaven?" So imagine Jesus
is standing here and you come ask Jesus
said, "Oh good master, what should I do
to inherit the kingdom of heaven?" Best
opportunity now to tell him this is and
we know the prophets of God are the best
advisers. That's right. Yeah. They're
going to tell you what is the best
thing. They're not going to tell you
something. Jesus said, "Why you calling
me good? No one good except God alone."
Then he said, "Keep the commandments of
God." That's right. And he's referring
to what? When Jesus said to the young
boy, "Keep the commandments of God."
What was he referring to? The law of
Moses. The law of Moses. Okay. Which
many of you don't do? Okay. So, he says,
"Keep the commandments of God." Then the
young boy said, "I have been doing it
since I was young." Yes. Jesus said to
him, "But you are lacking in one thing."
That's right. The young boy said, "What
is it?" He said, "Give your wealth away
and follow me." So Jesus in that moment,
he never said, "You want to be saved?
Believe I'm going to die for your sins
and you'll be fine. But where he said
they keep the commandments of that's the
first thing keep the commandments of
God. He said follow me though but which
one is more important. Okay brother if I
ask you what is the most important thing
you're going to tell me the last one
first. You're going to tell me the most
important thing first. Both are true. No
but brother the first thing he told him
keep the commandments of
God. So if the commandment of God was
not that important which was important
to you is the commandment of God or
believe Jesus that for your sins?
It's the same. It's the same thing.
Okay. But according to Paul, it's not
much because Paul said it's not about
the law anymore. It's about faith.
That's right. The law the law of
Moses. No. No. Let me finish. Let me
finish. Let me finish. Let me finish. I
was speaking. I'm going to let you
finish. I was speaking. Anyway, so he
said, "Follow me." All right. And also
we can go to the Old Testament. None of
the rather in the Old Testament rebuke
the belief of Jesus that you have which
is anything that is been hanged or on a
been hanged on a cross is cursed. That's
why Paul he said Jesus became cursed. So
you believe Jesus became cursed. I
believe Jesus is holy all the time. I
don't believe Jesus cursed. You believe
Jesus become cursed. He he was a sin
bearer. A bearer of sins. The Bible say
become cursed because of our sins.
Cursed. The word is been used cursed.
Don't that's what you doing. Yeah. You
are looking for anything to run away
from the truth because because we don't
know we don't know ancient Greek. We
don't understand how to mis translation.
No, but we don't his intention in the
word we can misunderstand. No, because
that's why we need because he's caught
in the Old Testament and the Old
Testament says the same wording. Anyone
that is hanged on a tree or a cross is
cursed. So the word cursed is used in
the Old Testament and is used in the New
Testament. So therefore there's no
mistransation.
Do you believe Jesus cursed? No. He
became cursed. No, but we we don't
understand his intention in
this. We give Jesus a better status than
you do. I tell you why. I give him a
better We give him a better status than
you do. If you ask if you ask I know you
love him, but we give him better status.
We believe that God made someone else
look like him and he didn't they didn't
actually crucify him. But you know the
cross the symbol of someone what you
believe is your god was crucified. Does
that give you life when you think about
it?
So we enter he entered willingly into
his he wasn't forced into that entered
willingly as a self believe he was
humiliated. What is what is the but that
is the foundation of no please let me
sorry go in Muhammad got revelation from
Gabriel. Yeah. I just want to know at
that time at that time that
moment and
then corrupted at that time. Was it
after or before? No, it was corrupted
before. Yeah. No, no, it was corrupted
before. Yeah. I mean, we can go back and
see. I just want to know. Um, yeah. So,
before was corrupted the Torah before
Jesus came along? Uh, was the Torah
before Jesus came? Jesus was corrupted.
Yeah.
That's why in Jeremiah 88, it shows you
that it was corrupt even before the time
of Jeremiah. You know it says Jeremiah
88. No, it's not that. Just No, but I'm
going to I'm going to I'm going to give
you a proof that it was corrupt before
Jesus. Not from the Quran, from your own
book. Okay. In Jama 88, he says, "How
can you claim the law of God with us
when the scribes have corrupted it?"
Falsified it. No, it's just that just
yesterday I went to the Quran just to
read and notice I had to read the as
well to see the context behind it. Yeah,
cuz I can't just read one. Yes. What am
I just reading for you? Just read the
verse. So Quran,
we send Jesus
confirming the law that has come before
him. We send him the gospel therefore
was guidance and light and confirming
the law that came before him and
guidance of admiration of those for
Allah. So I just want to know, we're not
in 610 AD. We're just in 30 AD. This is
500 years. At that time was the
Torah non-corrupted was corrupted
because that's what Allah sent Jesus to
rectify it. But Jesus confirms it. Yeah.
It confirms is from God. And confirm
also mean to rectify what is the truth
and to falsify what is falsehood. Like
in the Quran Allah prophet Muhammad came
to confirm which is confirm the
word believes. Yes. From God. That's
from God. But also to rectify it. That's
why I'm showing you even Jeremiah, your
own prophet, he says it's been
corrupted. So what teaching what Allah
says is true. Allah
said they used to hear if I put the word
correctly. I hope they used to hear
speech of Allah or the to be safe on a
safe side the meaning of it. They used
to hear speech of Allah. Why they used
to sorry they used to change it. Yes.
Yes. Allah mentioned the the rabbis you
know they used to change and even we can
go back to I see what is saying it was
corrupted but Jesus had the authority
from Allah saying which is true. Yeah it
was true to verify. So my only problem
is
that once the the Tanak was corrupted
then Jesus came along with the obviously
I don't understand Quran but I could
tell it wasn't given book it was given
orally because Jesus was the word of
Allah I mean Allah of course it was it
was inspired but it was a traveler he
said so he would obviously like speak
the and they will write down the
companion yeah the Quran but my only
thing is this I was I wasn't a Christian
born in 622 when this verse was given
According to Muhammad in one of the
hadith that the name the right letters
in the Bible the Jews and the Christians
have no right to say there isn't. So I'm
just thinking a Christian back then can
find the word but the Bible in my book
doesn't. So it does there's different
opinions amongst even the the word which
is uh it's been used in a Greek uh
where's the the Greek word even there's
the difference if
is in Arabic or something like that cuz
I haven't the interpretations no yeah
yeah because even in your own book you
can go back to the Greek word and they
differ how you pronounce it if you
there's a way to pronounce it will be
pronounced as Ahmed yes there's a deep
research about it you can check
phonetics was Yeah, I don't know. Now,
what is the word? It's
just the word. It's a bloody English.
It's a Greek word anyway. Greek word.
Yeah, it's a Greek word commentator you
guys.
He said that the the word itself, the
letters is in the Bible. So obviously I
don't know what's his opinion. Yeah, but
mentioned this other mentioned mean
praising him. Yeah, true, true. Yeah, it
just I'm just I'm just following his
criteria, but he's saying to the what
Muhammad is saying to the Christians
that you can find. So I just want to
know the Christians must have had a
different book through Muhammad's time.
We don't find the word. No, no, no, no.
It's not because why the Christians in
the Arab Peninsula there's no Christians
like you by the way cuz you know what
you don't do sometimes as a Catholic was
doing here as well. You make it seem
everyone it was like remember there's
east church and church of the west and
there's many churches. No, but but they
were one wait there's there's a
historian he's Egyptian Christian
historian and he was mentioning some
sects within Christianity in the Arab
peninsula one of Mariam there were sex
that believed Jesus and his mother both
of them were gods can I say that's why
if you read the Quran the verse sorry if
you read the verse Allah said
to oh Jesus son Mary he said the people
take me and my mother go beside Allah.
Allah is speaking about Christians at
that time. Even the the Catholics do the
same thing. Look they pray to Mary which
is taking a godly side. Are you
Catholic? Yes. Okay. You pray to Mary as
well. Do you ask my wife Catholic? But
yes but do you ask for prayer? Yeah. No.
No. You don't ask anyone to pray for
you. Not dead person. No, no, no, no.
But uh for example, you ask someone to
pray. Yeah, someone's alive. Why don't
you why don't you ask uh god? No, it's
better to do directly. Yeah. Why? Why?
But why would you ask someone to pray? I
don't ask Allah directly. You never ask.
Is it permissible to ask someone to
pray? Not dead. Someone alive. She's
alive. Where? Where is she? She's in
heaven. That's our belief. Okay. Prophet
Muhammad's alive.
Okay. Do you accept that? Not in
Christianity, you know. But he's in
heaven as well. So why why is Prophet
Muhammad alive? People in the same
place. We don't believe Muhammad is in
heaven. We believe Mary, the mother of
God, is in heaven. So we can ask for her
intercession just like I asked someone
to pray for me. Pray for me, please. Did
Mary pray to us directly to God or pray
for herself?
She asks God on our behalf. Just like if
I ask my friend to pray for me, they ask
God. He just prayed through Mary or pray
to God directly.
Jesus prayed to Godirect. Okay. So we
Muslim pray to God directly. He pray
through Mary. God
you ask your friend for prayer. No.
Better off to not ask. Better of to not
ask. Is it permissible in Islam? As long
he's alive and righteous, she is alive.
No, she's not alive. So she never died.
No, she she was she was assumed into
heaven. So So assumptions. So she was
risen. She never died as well. Just like
Jesus. She her body died just like
Christ died. Oh, she died. Is it a dogma
of the the church? Alhamdulillah. Islam.
Good. You can't you never asked someone
for prayer. No, I mean I did in the
past. Someone No, why not? This is a
good thing. In Islam, you allowed to do
the condition. Don't do it as a habit.
Secondly, you're doing it because you
want this person to to carry out a
because they have a close relationship.
No, no. Because you this this you're not
going to ask me. This why this why
people start worshiping righteous people
cuz they start believing they are better
than themselves. That's why Islam in the
Quran Allah told us to ask him directly.
Okay. Are you
hear sorry? Allah told us to ask him
directly. So which one is better off is
to ask Allah directly. All right. That's
it.
Yeah.
Which is the an old speech that was
basically now way of saying that he's no
what I'm saying they have different
scriptures because if you read the B the
book of bar element most of scriptures
even the Christians in the west in the
east they have different scriptures like
for example one of the scripture one the
gospel clearly mentioned Jesus was not
killed and he was saved by God. You can
read I have the book. Yes. And it we
discovered it is manuscript and he says
that there were people who believed in
this book to be from Are you talking you
have to understand my point. I'm not
saying it's correct or not. What I'm
saying I'm showing you Christians stop
making it seem that you are only the
people who are Christians. There are
other Christians who have different
scriptures. So when the Quran sometimes
address a Christian doesn't mean he has
to address you all the time. Can I say
something? Can I say something? So these
Christians were not from the apostles.
They did not agree. Okay. And we were
going back to the same point. They're
not from the apostles. They not they
didn't agree with the teaching of the
apostles because they believe some
apostles. They were not apostles. Paul
was he apostles of Jesus? Uh only by
only by virtue of his revelation by
Christ. But always in submission to the
authority of the apostles. Yes. What was
the problem between what was the problem
between Paul and James Jesus
halfbrother?
Very minor dispute.
A minor dispute on theology. It was a
lie. It was question. was because they
when Paul came to Jerusalem is they said
is it true that you're going around and
you say it's not about it's not about
the law anymore it's about faith and he
said yes they said okay go slaughter
sheep yes and he did it now when you go
to the to the to Jesus to Paul's letters
clearly said it's not about the law it's
about faith believe in Jesus died for
your sins so he did say it so he lied to
Jesus half brother but but did did
Jesus's half brother believe and you
missed the point he did lie
Historically is known he did lie. Lie.
Yeah. That's why Paul what he's doing he
said if anyone comes with the gospel
other than this do not believe in him.
Why? He wants to start what do
counseling the other ones who were more
closer to Jesus than him. He was he was
he was always communicating with the
apostles. He he spoke to the apostles
and they came to agreements together in
some stuff is not true. Some stuff has
been li anyway because I can show you.
He came to agreements. Paul he said that
Paul he was in communication with the
apostles. Yes. You would agree? Yeah
that's it. That's my point. My point. So
there are people who more followers of
James James J halfb brother. There are
some people who are followers of
Barnabas. Some people follow and they
had their own scripture. They believe
that scripture came from God. You
understand? So as the Quran speak about
scripture just always make sure don't
make it seem that the only scripture
that that was around is your scripture.
Okay? Because we know historically
speaking there were many scriptures
circulating around the world and they
were called the gospels of Jesus or the
gospel of such and such a apostle. Can I
say one thing?
So, so St. Paul says, "I'm I'm an
apostle not worthy to be called an
apostle." The least of the apostles. So,
he was in communion with the apostles um
under their submission and authority, he
spoke and proclaimed Christ. Always in
communion with the apostles. Paul, I'll
tell you what about Paul. Paul when he
couldn't defeat Christianity or the true
followers of Jesus by killing them and
they were strong in their religion, he
changed the tactic. He pretended to
become a true follow of Jesus and he
corrupted Jesus teaching from within. He
was unable to do it from outside and he
corrupted it. That's why he said in his
in his letter if he goes to someone
without a law he will pretend to be
someone without a law. If he goes to
someone with a law he will be with a law
basically hypocrite. So you go to a
Christian I have a cross I go to a
Jewish I put the thing. So basically
it's a Yeah. But you're you're do you
believe just because you follow I don't
know you sacrifice an animal that you
are justified in front of what I'm
saying can you trust some can you trust
someone who clearly telling you he's a
hypocrite can you trust him
he's free from the claim
can you trust someone okay imagine you
know I'm a Muslim but you believe
someone can change not every two seconds
not every two seconds he changes Imagine
you see me now. Imagine you see me now.
Yeah. When I come Muslim
tomorrow, you see me with a cross. Then
the day after you see me with the Jewish
thing. Yeah. Then the day after you see
me with the Hindu uh what they call it p
they call it I don't know what they call
what they call red thing. Anyway
painting okay painting or you know if
boys go he's going crazy or he's
pretending to be something. That's what
is Paul teaching. Anyway, what we say to
you, look clearly, I want to give you
something. Why even though there's a
huge war against Islam, listen carefully
on the mainstream media, clearly there's
propaganda against Islam. Clearly, I
don't know. Maybe we don't know that.
You know, we respect non-Muslim outside
agree with that. I would say I would say
there's propaganda against uh um theism
as it against God. Yes, brother. Name
one Christian country in the last 15
years has been bombed.
Iraq, Afghanistan, Somalia before the
Algeria before why the Christian
countries why me why they attacking and
remember that's why Islamophobic
Islamophobic came because why hatred
against Islam became very high in the
western world based upon what based upon
the mainstream media spreading lies and
misinformation the point here is even
though there's a huge war against Islam
yet the fastest growing religion in the
western world not in Algeria Morocco In
the western world when there is doubt
that Islam oppress women when there's a
doubt that you have to force your
daughters to get married people are
accepting Islam and Christianity is
dying if you read the newspaper a month
last month he mentions that many
churches are turning into swimming pools
Christians had enough cross to swim but
can I say something I'd say to say
America is a Christian nation I wouldn't
say that with much confidence because
yeah I don't think there's much evidence
of that Britain a Christian country
Sorry. Is Britain Christian country? Um,
not not like it used to be. France is a
Christian country. No, not like it used
to. So you have no Christian. It's
Daniel. That's my point.
But you're saying that we that America,
Christian nation, are bombing Islamic. I
don't think that's true because Bush
said, God told him Bush said God told
him a dream. It doesn't matter what
clearly clearly. Look, I'll show you
clearly. I say what is it the evidence
to pal? I'll give you Palestine. Look
what happened to Palestine. Our brothers
and sisters, may Allah aid them.
Clearly there's a genocide. Clearly
Netanyahu is killing innocent people
everything. Why America and Britain and
France do not move with their weapons.
But Iraq there was no clear genocide.
Nothing. America and and Britain and
France they go so merciful about
Muslims. They invade Iraq. Why don't
they invade soal is to stop the
genocide? But what I'm saying is I
wouldn't I wouldn't say I wouldn't
compare. Is a logical corruption. That's
what I'm saying. No, I agree. I agree.
If he's a Muslim, they're too quick to
come and save them and kill the Muslims.
But if it's a non-Muslim,
Libya, it always gets complicated when
it's brown people. They can kill us. If
you're brown, stick around. It always
gets If you're white, you're right.
That's right. If you're black, get to
the back. You don't believe that's what
they say. That's what they say. You're
talking to kill brown people. That's
fine. Never a white person. This the
reality. Ukraine. Ukraine. Look how they
portrayed. We believe there's
oppression. No doubt. And we stand with
the people of Ukraine innocent people.
Yes. However, Muslim noted killing
innocent people is haram all the time.
It's forbidden all the time. And guess
Muslims or non-Muslims. You listen us.
Maybe you don't know me very well. When
the ISIS was coming around and they were
killing innocent people, we stood
openly. Even in the '90s, we our
scholars fought against openly cuz
killing innocent people is forbidden
Islam. Yes, in Islam there is a jihad
which is legislate jihad to remove the
oppressors not to bring about
oppression. The jihad of ISIS or the
jihad of the path of Satan by killing
innocent people. So however with Iraq
look how many countries they got
involved claiming they want to save the
Muslims from the Muslims. But look
what's happened to people of Gaza tiny
place prison and they've been killed
children. Tell me please with us
corrational argument why the western
world do not take their army and weapons
weapons to Israel. They're giving
weapons to Israel. No, they're given
weapons to the oppressor. Just what I
said. I said that why is it okay for the
Ukrainians to resist an occupation but
the Palestinians can't? Why should the
Palestinians have to die? What is the
difference between the Palestinians and
Ukrainians? What's the difference? Why
is it the Palestinians cannot resist
occupation? But we defend the
Ukrainians. It's ridiculous.
But we leave the Palestinians to die.
It's unfair. I agree. I agree. But you
have to be fair as well. There's many
non-Muslims. I agree. But what I'm sure
there's many non-Muslims, Christians
war, Jewish war. They stand with the
Muslim against oppression. But what I'm
saying overall, the mainstream media is
portraying as Gaza. They are terrorists.
Absolutely. You see, because they're
fighting for their rights. You know,
some are calling it out. Yeah. Yeah.
Catholics are calling it out. But what
I'm saying is Catholic. Yeah, but what
I'm saying is America, Britain, these
are not Christian nations. We
can't possess Christian Christianity.
But you see, you think that, but they're
not actually Christian. That's what I
think. Well, they disagree. They
disagree. When they come out to do
whatever England England, yeah, yeah,
that's what I mean. England is good.
Okay, let me let me show you. Let me
show you something. In Christianity, you
ask me a few question. Let me ask you a
question about something else. In
Christianity, I'm trying to get that
last point. Last one. One minute before
we go to last point. In Christianity,
you allow it. You're not a woman not
allowed to ask for divorce except if
there is
fornication in Christianity. No,
cuz they have this. No, they don't. In
the Bible, Jesus said, "You're not
allowed to ask for divorce here." Yeah.
No divorce. No divorce. Yeah. No
divorce. That's why Church of England
came about because in Christianity,
you're not allowed to ask divorce except
for fornication. If the woman fornicate
but maybe not even then but yeah even
then it's not. Yeah. Even then it's a
bit Yeah. Okay. So watch this. Yeah. So
if the
husband abuses wife physically abuses
her according to Jesus she's not allowed
to ask for divorce. Islam she's allowed
to ask. No the question is whether she
can remarry. The question is whether
it's not whether you should separate.
Yes you should. For your safety you
should separate. But the question is no.
Can she ask for divorce? Can can you can
you remarry?
remarry is next step cuz you cannot
remarry if you're not divorced first ask
get the divorce then remarry baba and
you can't you can know the marriage but
you can't ask for divorce that's what
I'm saying so so clearly Christianity
oppress women stop in the in the sense
that you have to get so she can marry
another man but Islam you know Islam you
know Islam you know Islam many people I
hope there's no children watching this
but in Islam the woman have a right if
the man is not giving her is not
fulfilling her desire physically she's
ask a right to not stay with him because
why one of the purpose of marriage is to
make sure to protect her virginity to
protect her honor everything so if
you're not fulfilling her right then
she's allowed so therefore it's not
lying that is step oppressed woman what
we can see no Jesus I don't believe that
Christianity oppressed women